bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique après
l'élection d' emmanuel macron et
l'écrasante majorité obtenue par la
république en marche aux législatives de
nombreuses personnalités politiques de
droite comme de gauche ont quitté la vie
publique et débuter une nouvelle vie
battus ou partie avant même de tenter
une nouvelle candidature ils ont entamé
une reconversion ou ont tout simplement
pour certains repris leur en ciel devis
au plan national najat vallaud belkacem
nathalie kosciusko morizet bernard
cazeneuve
cécile duflot ou encore roselyne
bachelot ont choisi de changer de vie
alors est ce facile de trouver du
travail après en plusieurs mandats
politiques quels critères on déterminer
leur choix
la vie politique leur manque t'elle leur
parcours les est-il ou au contraire p
style dans leur nouvelle vie peut-on
faire de la politique autrement après
avoir quitté la vie publique et l'arène
politique en elle même on en débat avec
nos invités en direct ce matin
christophe sirugue bonjour bonjour vous
êtes ancien maire de chalon sur saône
ancien député de saône et loire et
ancien ministre
vous avez quitté la vie politique après
la fin de votre mission ministérielle à
bercy c'était en 2017 bernard depierre
bonjour je vous êtes ancien député et
ancien conseiller général de côte-d'or
vous avez quitté la vie politique en
2012 après votre défaite aux
législatives dans la première
circonscription de côte-d'or merci à
tous les deux d'avoir accepté cette
invitation est vous qui nous regarde et
vous pouvez bien sûr commenter cette
émission avec le hashtag dit mme paul
bourgogne alors j'ai envie de vous
demander d'abord comment ça va cette
nouvelle vie christophe sirugue
écoutez ça va très bien sanaa très bien
d'abord parce que je crois qu'il faut
distinguer deux choses il ya la question
de l'engagement politique pour lequel je
n'ai pas le sentiment d'être moins
engagés aujourd'hui qui errent dans la
défense des valeurs auxquelles je crois
puis à la question d'avoir une activité
politique qui fait que vous n'appelez
atteint avoir d'activité professionnelle
à côté qui est un autre sujet se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui je peux avoir
et un engagement politique que je
maintiens et en même temps un engagement
professionnel qui ferra vous faites une
nuance entre engagement politique et vie
politique j'ai toujours combattu l'idée
que la politique c'était un métier
à partir du moment où c'est pas un
métier ce sont des fonctions qui vous
sont confiées pendant
tant donné à l'évidence aujourd'hui je
continue à penser que je fais de la
politique et en plein d'engagement que
j'ai sans être forcément un d'élus
politiques et ça vous va bien pour
l'instant en train de vie bernard
depierre vous avez la même vision on
peut faire de la politique même quand on
n'est plus élu ça va de soi il faut
d'abord différencier des engagements
politiques et la vie publique
parce qu'en fait on a un mandat on a
demandé trois mandats élus lequel élu
départemental élu national c'est une
chose
nos convictions politiques en sont une
autre et incontestablement on doit
pouvoir différencier les gens tout en
continuant d activité professionnelle
c'est mon coeur est toujours travailler
en étant pourtant 35 ans dans la vie
publique 24 ans adjoint au maire de
dijon 14 ans conseil général 10 ans
l'assemblée nationale mais pendant tout
ce parcours j'étais directeur des
ressources humaines consultant ans
président d'une société de formation qui
existe toujours et qui marche quand on
arrête la vie politique quand on arrête
ses mandats c'est plus facile j'imagine
de reprendre pied intégralement dans le
monde du travail quand on va garder une
activité
c'est plus facile mais c'est aussi une
rupture difficile à vivre il faut bien
voir les choses simplement on retrouve
les vraies amies les vraies valeurs
celles et ceux qui nous sont chers
ils ont voulu un regard différent sur
d'entonner et politique on n'a pas de
vrais amis y ait de faux amis dans la
vie publique c'est quoi les courtisans
des gens qui ont des coeurs besoin de
vous tout à fait c'est une vraie vraie
aller quand vous êtes supposé avoir un
peu de pouvoir vous avez forcément
beaucoup de gens qui vous aiment
le jour où vous êtes battus vous avez
les vrais amis qui reste et ça c'est
important
en même temps ça permet de les
identifier ça au moins ce mérite là mais
ce que ce qui vient d'être dit est
parfaitement vrai vous avez toute une
série de personnes qui sont autour de
vous
dont vous ne voyez pas forcément
toujours qu'ils sont là par intérêt mais
vous constatez lorsque vous êtes battus
oui parce que ce que vous êtes battus ou
lorsque vous arrêtez la vie publique
tout d'un coup qu'est ce qui se passe le
téléphone sonne beaucoup moins non le
téléphone sonne beaucoup moins un
certain nombre de gens qui traversait la
rue pour venir vous saluer ne vous ont
pas vu est incontestablement ça choque
un petit peu ça fait un peu de peine
mais il faut réagir et en tout état de
cause
retrouvez et son engagement le mien est
clair il est dans le sport il est dans
la vie professionnelle apprentissage
formation et j'ai aussi présidé après
avoir fini mes mandats le fils d'achille
est mort vitis pendant huit ans
président six ans vice-président j'ai
rendu beaucoup de services dans le
domaine du logement social et j'en suis
fier parce que c'est vraiment un besoin
capital pour ne courir que les gens vont
continuer à vous saluer dans la rue
quand même tout à fait et à me demander
des interventions pour éviter pour un
logement hlm évidemment est ce que la
politique christophe sirugue elle s'est
souvent présenté comme une drogue dure
dont la désintoxication est parfois
délicate voire impossible à ce que vous
avez l'impression que que qu'on est
drogué à la politique quand on en fait
depuis tant d'années comme vous vous en
avez vous avez eu quand même beaucoup de
mandat pendant de longues années
moi je pense que un homme ou une femme
politique qui dit qu'il fera plus jamais
de politique
ces suspects parce que en effet je pense
que faire le choix de s'investir dans le
débat public de porter des fonctions
c'est forcément un choix dans lequel
vous vous mettez complètement et je ne
crois pas qu'on fasse de la politique
par hasard je pense que c'est une
conception que l'on a du fait que c'est
peut-être plus difficile que d'être
simplement devant son poste de
télévision et de commenter que de
s'engager véritablement moi j'ai
toujours choisi de m'engager dans des
associations dans des organisations
syndicales dans le parti politique
auquel j'appartiens et j'ai le sentiment
que ça fait partie de moi je disais il
ya pas très longtemps je pense que je
resterai militants toute ma vie
militant c'est une chose mais élu c'est
une autre chose
est-ce qu'on peut s'en passer comment
vous avez fait bernard depierre pour
vous en passer moi je m'en suis pas
passé
venu gaulliste lorsque j'étais lycéen ou
lycée lamartine à mâcon ce que j'ai
rencontré le général je suis resté
gaulliste je suis toujours golly
j'appartiens toujours républicain dans
une période difficile on va en parler
est incontestablement d'autres ne sont
que des mangeurs de soupe
ils vont je vais dire à la ramasse mais
c'est pas du tout ma conception des
choses
quand vous dites c'est à vous avez
finalement garder vos convictions malgré
l'écho demande à l'élu comme christophe
sirugue ont siégé pas sur les mêmes
bancs y en avait des relations tout à
fait conviviale respectueuse
c'était un autre monde on a parlé du
regard des gens tout à l'heure mais
c'est de pierre disait que finalement
les gens des fois ne traversez plus la
rue pour venir des bourgeoises que le
regard des gens a changé sur vous
christophe sirugue
la dernière fois qu'on s'est rencontrés
je travaille pas de secret c'était à
bercy pour une interview dans votre
bureau de secrétaire d'état à
l'industrie a bat aujourd'hui on se
retrouve peut-être à chalon sur saône
oui mais encore une fois je pense qu'il
faut pas non plus globalisé il ya
quelques personnes dont je disais tout à
l'heure que ils se présentaient comme
des proches qui subitement ne le sont
plus le soir de l'élection lorsque vous
êtes battus al'inverse il ya tous ces
citoyens que je côtoie quand je suis à
chalon je suis tous les week-ends à
chalon avec lesquels la relation est
restée une relation sympathique je crois
qu'à un moment il faut faire la
distinction dans ces éléments là et puis
surtout enfin moi j'ai toujours été
extrêmement reconnaissant devant les
électeurs moi j'ai pas fait les grandes
écoles
il se trouve que j'ai eu un parcours
comme on dit étage par étage des boys
tep et si j'ai pu faire c'est parce
qu'il ya des gens qui m'ont fait
confiance
le minimum c'est au moins de leur être
reconnaissant de ça j'ai vécu des choses
exceptionnelles que probablement je
n'imaginais pas vivre quand vous
mentionnez l'expérience ministérielle
qui a été la mienne même si on peut
discuter de ces expériences là cela
étant je n'ai pu le faire que parce
qu'il ya des gens qui m'ont fait
confiance qu'ils m'ont accompagné et ça
je ne les oublie pas qu'est-ce qui est
le plus dur
le téléphone qui ne sonne plus être plus
ou moins sollicité une forme de peur du
vide oui je pense enfin ce qui est le
plus dur un dallage accablant oui non
c'est pas tellement ça je pense qu'en
tout cas moins pour ce qui était le plus
dur c'est d'avoir démarré jeune en
politique ce qui fait qu'à un moment
quant à 52 ans
vous retrouvez sans autre activité que
celle que vous aviez en tant
qu'engagement politique la question de
savoir qu'est ce que je vais faire
comment comment je vais mettre en
application ou en avant les éléments que
j'ai appris vous n'avez pas de vf
quand vous avez fait de la politique
vous n'avez pas de valorisation des
algues quand vous exercez un métier il
est que ça change d'ailleurs tout à fait
parce que quand vous exercez un métier
on est capable de vous dire vous avez
acquis telles compétences telles
compétences quand vous sortez d'un
environnement politique à vous en avez
considère que j'ai acquis des
expériences et comme n'importe qui qui
est agi mais elle n'y a pas d'élément
qui vous permettent de le mettre en
avant bernard depierre sur sur ce qui
est le plus dur quand ça s'arrête quand
on passe à autre chose c'est quoi en
fait je ne suis pas passé autre chose
puisque je travaillais pendant mes
mandats oui j'ai continué vous disiez
une autre manière échange avec plus de
disponibilité mais quand on n'a plus
débuté il ya des choses qui changent et
les choses qui fut alors qu'est-ce qui
est le plus dur c'est le téléphone qui
ne sonne plus l'agenda vie donc non
c'est beaucoup c'est l'ancien les
réorganiser devrait organiser sa vie
lorsque l'on est député lundi soir on
prend tgv pour la paris siège et
éventuellement la nuit le jeudi on entre
dans sa circonscription
les vendredis samedis c'est quinze
manifestations minimum jusqu'au dimanche
soir ça ça s'est arrêté bien évidemment
mais comme j'aime le sport est comme les
sportifs dijonnais les côte-d'oriens
même je continue à aller les voir et a
même des maires de toutes sensibilités
qui me demandent des conseils quand ils
construisent une salle terrain de
football
parce que j'ai aussi siégé au cnds et
j'ai apporté j'ose dire à la côte d'or à
la bourgogne
de très nombreuses installations
sportives est ce qu'il ya des
différences on a invité un ancien élu de
droite et un ancien élu de gauche est ce
qu'elle est différent c'est ce qu'on le
vit plus difficilement quand on est allé
lui droite un élu de gauche christophe
sirugue jeu à la place de mon collègue
parce que c'est quand même tout cas pour
ce qui me concerne
passée cette période au cours de
laquelle doute on se dit qu'est ce que
je vais faire
finalement vous avez deux options vous
vous dites
allez j'essaie de me mettre un peu à
l'abri et puis je retenterai ma chance
lors d'une prochaine échéance électorale
est ce que vous vous êtes dit pas
forcément on les voit qu'on les évacue
jamais voilà c'est toujours un peu
présent on verra ce que l'avenir nous ne
me réserve
cela étant fourni en option et la
deuxième c'est de dire je vais en
profiter pour faire autre chose moi je
n'avais jamais eu d'expérience secteur
privé j'avais envie d'aller dans le
secteur privé parce que je pense que ça
complète la formation qui était la
mienne la personnalité qui est la mienne
et donc j'ai fait le choix de me dire je
salon privé que je veux c'est parce que
vous vous étiez un peu un professionnel
de la politique à la fois dans le
militantisme les parties attachés
parlementaires etc
vous avez toujours été donc vous aviez
besoin d'autre chose
j'avais envie d'autre chose surtout il
se trouve que le fait d'avoir à la fois
beaucoup travaillé sur les questions
droit du travail sur les questions
économiques sociales
le ministère de l'industrie dans lequel
j'ai eu à assumer quelques
responsabilités m'ont aussi permis de
rencontrer des dirigeants d'entreprise
et pour répondre à votre question il
faut sortir des clichés l'espèce d'idées
selon lequel les dirigeants d'entreprise
ne parlerait car des gens de droite
n'est pas vrai je veux dire à un moment
il parle à des gens dont ils ont le
sentiment qu'ils ont fait leur boulot
quand ils ont le sentiment qu'ils sont
sérieux et de ce point de vue là j'ai eu
cette chance de pouvoir avoir des
interlocuteurs qui m'ont permis ensuite
d'avoir l'emploi que j'ai aujourd'hui
alors je vous ai demandé s'il y avait
une différence quand c'était droite ou
de gauche blessé répondent aussi bernard
depierre mais je lui rajouter une
deuxième question
j'entendais quelques temps après
sa sortie de la vie publique roselyne
bachelot qui est encore bien dans la vie
publique et la vie médiatique dire que
c'était moins compliqué pour les femmes
politiques parce qu'elle gardait tout le
temps les pieds sur terre parce que
quand elles sont mères de famille etc
elles ont elles ont une vie bien chargée
et qui les oies les éloigne pas trop des
réalités des français qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
je peux pas parler à la place d'une
femme
en tout état de cause en ce qui me
concerne je vis mieux ma vie de famille
je rends compte plus facilement toutes
celles et tous ceux que j'aime
c'était pas le cas pendant ces trente
cinq ans de vie publique
mais ma chance et j'ai trois vit une vie
professionnelle une vie publique et une
vie sportive très engagé et
qu'incontestablement j'ai gardé des
attaches dans les trois domaines
je ne sais pas de quoi sera fait
l'avenir mais en tout état de cause
aujourd'hui j'ai un meilleur équilibre
de vie j'ai moins de contraintes
même si je suis au travail du lundi au
dimanche alors certains politiques
parlent de dépression après une fonction
ministérielle où un mandat de député ou
de mer et cetera quand on perd une
élection on parle aussi des ors de la
république alors bercy avait pas
beaucoup d'or dans votre ministère mais
dans ceux d'à côté il y en avait on va
peut-être voir une photo du du conseil
des ministres du salon murat du conseil
des ministres parce que là effectivement
il ya d or est ce que ça ça manque
ou est-ce qu'on on passe vite à autre
chose normes et sans langue de bois
qu'est ce que c'est rude parce que non
mais vous avez repris votre volant sans
problème enfin oui enfin heureusement
jeudi et ceux qui me connaissent savent
très bien que lorsque j'étais à chalon
je n'avais pas de chauffeur et donc y
compris quand j'étais ministre
d'ailleurs et que c'est moi même qui
conduisait la voiture avec un officier
de sécurité puisque c'est obligatoire
mais ce salariat vous l'avez de laponie
oui je les bien connus en effet mais
enfin encore une fois faut là encore ah
pardon mais surtout des clichés c'est
pas la langue de bois mais surtout des
clichés c'est bon on n'est pas tous des
politiques qui nous en mettront plein
les poches et qui sommes extrêmement
satisfaits
il ya une fascinante et vit en
difficultés je comprends les facilités
de vie enfin oui c'est moi quand vous
consacrez votre vie 24 heures sur 24
il faut aussi qu'on vous aide à pouvoir
l'assurer à un moment je pense qu'il
faut sortir de ces décès de ces espèces
dit dès que j'ai su oui ils disposent de
clichés
après encore une fois qu'il y à un
environnement qui vous fait
si dit le travail c'est une réalité je
ne le conteste pas bon enfin on sait
tous qu'on est là temporairement ou
alors si on le sait pas c'est le vrai
sujet peut-être là qu'il ya un vrai
problème
il ya choc après de tout à chacun
c'était violent elle est forcément
compté alors moi ont compté puisque j'ai
été nommé en septembre 2016 et je savais
quand même à peu près qu'il ya des
élections présidentielles on mai 2010
est donc je suis les cours la période
est déterminant ça relativise un peu les
choses
bernard depierre ça vous manque et
travail de l'assemblée nationale les
beaux salons dorés etc
seule l'assemblée nationale me manque
naturellement parce que j avais beaucoup
d'amis j'ai beaucoup travaillé en
commission d'abord des affaires sociales
puis des affaires de l'éducation et du
monde de la jeunesse du sport
j'ai été j'ai eu la chance j'ai été le
rapporteur de cette loi est l'auteur de
deux propositions de loi une très
importante celle sur le statut des
arbitres leur protection sociale pénales
et civiles et la deuxième très
importante aussi sur les stades de
l'euro 2016 est incontestablement on a
un peu de nostalgie de tout ce que l'on
a pu faire pour les autres
et lorsque je revois des collègues de
l'assemblée nationale quelle que soit
leur sensibilité
on évoque les bons souvenirs ayant parce
qu'en fait il y en a eu beaucoup
le restaurant le restaurant du huitième
étage ne sais pas restaurants étoilés
mais c'est un endroit où on se retrouve
avec beaucoup de plaisir
alors parmi ceux qui comme vous ont
changé de vie il y en a qui est bien
connu dans notre région il s'agit
d'arnaud montebourg l'ancien élu de
saône et loire et ancien ministre de
l'économie
il est revenu récemment sur ses terres
et on l'a suivi sur le marché de louhans
non plus pour récolter les voir mais
pour vendre son miel et promouvoir son
entreprise bleu blanc rouge françois
latour anthony borloo on a plus l'acacia
la lavande le tilleul les fleurs
sauvages à tous vendus en deux heures
sur le marché ce matin arnaud montebourg
il n'est plus ici pour distribuer des
tracts
mais pour vendre du miel et il n'a rien
perdu de sa verve abri
à fond le goûter ça me fait plaisir
l'ancien ministre comme un poisson dans
l'eau dans son rôle de vendeur
les clients l'apprécient il a du duel du
bug du bagout quoi un bon commercial
comme un bonhomme politique j'en fais
deux contraire mais certains n'ont pas
oublié leurs anciens élus et sont
contents de le croiser à nouveau
je crois que ils auraient tout à fait
l'envergure pour avoir une politique de
qualité par rapport à ce que l'on vit
aujourd'hui à passer qui est bien et qui
lui dire bon bah on va reconstruire
alors un éventuel retour en politique ni
deux mais pas forcément partagé par tous
les choses ont changé vous avez vu il ya
eu six mois de gilet jaune machin donc
la politique elle est en train de se
noyer vous savez à droite et à gauche on
ne sait plus trop non non c'est pas la
peine faux pas ah ben on vend pas du
channel et du dior un l'épaule tous
entre 5 et 7 euros
c'est moins cher que le diesel de
monsieur macro l'intéressé pour sa part
le clame il a tiré un trait sur la
politique
moi j'ai donné vingt ans de ma vie à la
france j'ai donné 18 ans à la saône et
loire je suis très fier de ce que j'ai
fait avant quand je serai la cuillère
d'un citoyen iman gueuler quand j'étais
député ou ministre et maintenant ils
donnent un petit billet pour acheter mon
miel c'est quand même plus agréable
voilà arnaud montebourg semble vraiment
avoir changé de vie même s'il semble
être toujours un petit peu en campagne
voilà arnaud montebourg sur le marché de
louhans c'était le 10 juin dernier
christophe cyrus est un département que
vous connaissez bien la saône et loire
et qui connaissez bien arnaud montebourg
pour avoir été dans le même parti tout
en ayant des options sans doute par
moment un petit peu divergentes
quand vous regardez sa nouvelle vie dans
le miel le miel made in france est ce
que vous vous dites qu'il continue à
faire de la politique autrement
mais je pense qu'arnaud est quelqu'un
qui est un peu comme moi c'est à dire
engagé aujourd'hui il est engagé sur un
combat différent qui est celui du made
in france c'est à dire la promotion de
la production de produits français ils
avaient déjà commis
l'ong a sion moi je serais tenté de dire
s'il s'épanouit dans cette activité là
tant mieux et j'en suis très heureuse en
voix et non non non je joue je passe
vraiment pour ajouter ces passages ce
que mes jeux comme j'ai toujours en tête
l'idée que quand vous avez fait de la
politique on va bien qu'on m'explique
que vous jamais jamais vous ne
recommencerez voilà j'écoutais arnaud et
j'avais le sentiment qu'il était déjà en
campagne comme d'hab on a l'impression
qu'on n'arrête jamais bernard depierre
ça vous inspire ce que fait arnaud
montebourg sur le miel made in france
le made in france je partage totalement
alors faire du millage et aucune
compétence
donc je ne l'avais pas non plus il
apprend je trouve cette idée séduisante
en tout état de cause est une
reconversion un peu curieuse on va dire
mais par contre sa conception de
promouvoir les produits made in france
c'est une conception je partage
totalement et conception qui vient du
monde politique puisqu'il s'est beaucoup
engagé en tant que ministre du
redressement productif antagonistes de
l'économie sur ces questions là on se
souvient la fameuse marinière d'arnaud
montebourg donc à une forme de
continuité ça veut dire que on peut en
dehors de l'arène politique à proprement
parler continue à faire de la politique
autrement selon vous mais on fait de la
politique parce qu'on a des convictions
ont fait pas de la politique simplement
comme ça par hasard donc si vous avez
des convictions qui sont chevillée au
corps à un moment vous voulez vous
finalement vous les défendez vous les
portez dans votre vie de tous les jours
dans vos comportements dans votre
relation et vos amis dans votre relation
professionnelle donc oui enfin moi je
n'ai pas le sentiment qu'il y est une
espèce de rupture même si en effet je
n'exerce plus les mêmes fonctions que
j'ai exercé avant même si j'ai retrouvé
la qualité de vie d'un jean d'un
dimanche face au caen on les avait joués
sur france 3 je vous attends des
dommages et le brésil avec vous mais
cela étant j'ai retrouvé une qualité de
vie du week-end qui est sans doute un
élément important pour les personnels
voilà mais cela étant encore une fois
j'ai le sentiment de ne pas être autre
chose que ce que j'étais avant en termes
de conviction et de et de valeurs vous
parliez christophe sirugue il ya un
instant de ce possible retour qui est
quelque part un peu toujours toujours
dans la tête on le sent bien arnaud
montebourg alors c'est nous qui lui
posons la question pour être très
honnête est ce que vous allez revenir
est ce que bon il dit qu'il a changé de
vie mais on voit bien dans ces allusions
emmanuel macron dans son combat que
elle titille un peu la tentation du
retour est ce qu'elle est toujours là
bernard depierre
on va parler de votre bord aussi puisque
nicolas sarkozy vient de publier un
ouvrage donc et on sait qu'il a tenté de
revenir aussi nicolas sarkozy a été
sauvagement abattus avant les
présidentielles
je partage complètement ses convictions
je suis pas convaincu qu'il va revenir
par contre la droite en aurait
certainement bien besoin
cependant on est incontestablement le
retour dans la vie politique est
sûrement plus difficile lorsqu'on a
perdu un grand combat comme une
présidentielle après une législative
j'ai pas vu le valéry giscard d'estaing
n'a jamais réussi à revenir par exemple
au premier plan sauf que les présidents
de la république ont eu le privilège de
siéger au conseil constitutionnel en
dans des conditions d'ailleurs
partenaire mais incontestablement songer
à revenir pour un homme comme nicolas
sarkozy ça doit le le titiller de temps
en temps je suis pas convaincu que ce
soit possible
après nicolas sarkozy et pour vous
est-ce que depuis 2012 vous êtes dire
moment donné je vais je vais reprendre
un combat politique je vais me lancer
dans une élection où est ce que vous
vous êtes dit non il faut que je passe à
autre chose
d'abord j'ai regardé ma carte d'identité
donc je me suis dit que j'avais l'âge de
raison
ceci est en baisse ceci étant je
rencontre des nerfs je rencontre chaque
jour sur le marché j'habite juste à
cause des marchés dijon des gens qui me
disent tu es sûrement le plus considérer
le plus apte à revenir quelques mois il
ya les municipales il ya pléthore de
candidats tout le monde veut être
candidat à la mairie de dijon
mais pour gagner la mairie de dijon il
faut avoir une équipe faut avoir un
leader faut avoir aussi un projet il
suffit pas de critiquer le maire sortant
c'est un peu simpliste est
incontestablement pour l'instant rien
n'est décidé
en tout l'état de cause je n'aiderai
qu'un candidat qu'ils méritent
mais vous n'excluez pas d'apporter votre
soutien entre les cas je l'exclus jamais
de porter mon soutien m'ont quant à
votre famille politique elle a bien
besoin alors tout à fait tout à fait
mais même chez l'autre côté il y en aura
aussi pour qu'il sauve si vous ne
comptez pas sur la famille
l'éthique qui en a bien besoin
christophe sirugue on l'a bien compris
que vous étiez en réserve je sais pas si
ce sont les bons mots mais quand tous
les cas vous étiez passé autre chose
vous allez maintenant une activité dans
le privé mais que la politique n'est
jamais très loin alors même question il
ya des élections dans quelques mois est
ce que chalon sur saône
c'est quelque chose que il revenir aux
sources redevenir maire de chalon sur
saône c'est quelque chose qui pourrait
vous tenter et là aussi sans langue de
bois
d'abord la priorité c'est de réussir
l'activité professionnelle qui est la
même la mienne oui j'ai pris des
engagements
je suis un associé du cabinet conseil
dans lequel je travaille
il ya des salariés qui sont dans ce
cabinet le minimum c'est que je
m'investisse pleinement ce que je fais
aujourd'hui
en plus ça me plaît donc ma priorité
pour pour l'instant c'est très clair
c'est d'être d'assumer l'activité
professionnelle qui est la mienne
aujourd'hui à côté de ça moi je j'habite
chalon contre un mois ce que j'entends
parfois la nuit j'ai pas l'intention de
vendre ma maison j'ai pas l'intention de
quitter chalon donc j'habite chalon sur
saône et j'entends bien au moment des
municipales participer je ne sais pas
comment
et participez du combat municipal
personnes européenne par exemple
oui même si alors fraîchement à la même
chose s'ils me font des comparaisons
entre les européennes et des élections
municipales alors je les laisse à cet
exercice là non mais bien évidemment que
je participerai alors après vous pouvez
participer
le sang est sur une liste vous pouvez
participer de plein de manières
possibles vous pouvez participer en
étant le premier tous âges étiez
candidat vous serez candidat pour le
parti socialiste évidemment mais à un
moment chez moi je suis socialiste
cela parce que le web et vous étiez
classe et un peu bacon macron compatible
quand vous étiez au gouvernement de
pierre lacaze mais excusez moi j'ai
quand même été candidat avec le poing et
la rose il avait pas beaucoup donc je
peux me regarder dans une glace à
contrairement à d'autres compatit
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas quelle
relation qu'ils ont avec leur conscience
mais ça les regarde
slight surtout avec la politique plutôt
de droite qui est développée aujourd'hui
donc je les laisse faire là dessus
cela étant pour ce qui me concerne je
suis socialiste je reste socialiste que
le parti dans lequel je suis connaissent
des difficultés c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire qu'il faille sans doute
imaginer autre chose
j'y travaille par ailleurs avec des amis
mais cela étant à un moment ou un autre
je ne changerai pas les valeurs de fond
qui sont les miennes il nous reste deux
minutes
est ce que votre départ de la vie
politique active a changé votre regard
sur la question du cumul des mandats
bernard depierre le cumul des mandats
dans le temps notamment on en parle
beaucoup
moi je suis convaincu qu'on ne pouvait
pas assumer une grande ville et mandat
de député ou un mandat de sénateur
par contre je suis convaincu que un
maire d'une petite commune aurait le
plus grand intérêt à garder son mandat
dans sa petite commune pour bien
connaître l'état des lieux aujourd'hui
et une déconnexion totale entre une
grande partie des députés à l'assemblée
nationale
certains sénateurs avec les problèmes de
la vie locale de conviction la première
c'est qu'il faut savoir limiter dans le
temps ça je suis assez favorable à cela
ses amours en parler je le sens de cause
à un moment il faut savoir limiter dans
le temps ça ça me paraît important par
contre je n'ai jamais été véritablement
favorable même si je vais voter mais au
fond de moi jamais véritablement
favorable à la dissociation entre un
sénateur maire ou un député maire est ce
que je constate aujourd'hui de
l'exercice de certains parlementaires
nouveaux parlementaires ne fait que
renforcer cette conviction c'est qu'à un
moment quand vous ne connaissez pas ce
qu'est le fonctionnement d'une
collectivité ou le fonctionnement local
et que vous avez le sentiment que vous
n'êtes finalement qu'un législateur et
que la circonscription c'est anecdotique
ben ouais on a pour pouvoir rester
conseiller municipal exactement je pense
qu'à un moment c'est que cette nécessité
la me paraît bon
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté de
répondre à ces questions et de débattre
aujourd'hui en direct merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis dans un instant un
point sur l'actualité régionale avec
clément janin suivi de la partie
nationale 2 dimanche en politique
francis letellier qui reçoit tient une
ancienne collègue à vous qui a changé de
camp annick girardin la ministre d
outre-mer bon dimanche à tous sur france
[Musique]